[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo so
juliet riaño y hoy los saludo desde casa
[Música]
el incendio que consumió el campo de
refugiados de moría el más grande de
europa volteó nuevamente los ojos del
continente hacia la isla griega de
lesbos un lugar que por años ha lidiado
con la llegada de miles de inmigrantes a
sus costas y que dice sentir el abandono
de europa frente al éxodo memoria más
vivían al menos 13 mil migrantes en un
albergue que fue pensado para la
recepción de poco más de dos mil
personas ahora el campo de refugiados
fue reducido a cenizas y los migrantes
quedaron sin lo poco que tenían ante la
emergencia a grecia abrió un refugio
temporal de acogida en un antiguo campo
de tiro del ejército algunos ya han sido
trasladados hasta allí pero otros se
niegan a alojarse en este lugar y por el
contrario exigen que se les permita
salir de la isla mientras todo esto
sucede los locales quieren que los
migrantes se vayan pero los países
europeos aún no cuentan con una política
clara para su reubicación
para resolver algunas preguntas que
quedan tras el incendio de moria
contactamos a veronica barroso portavoz
de refugio e inmigración de amnistía
internacional en españa a ella le
consultamos previamente sobre este nuevo
campo provisional de refugiados y el
pedido que hacen las organizaciones
humanitarias para una reubicación
definitiva desde amistad internacional
lo que estamos pidiendo y exigiendo es
que las autoridades griegas adopten
medidas urgentes inmediatas para poder
trasladar a estas personas que se
encuentran todavía en lesbos y que están
viviendo
en condiciones inhumanas a la intemperie
que puedan ser trasladadas a la
península que también se les facilite
ayuda humanitaria y que se les pueda
trasladar a alojamientos que sean
adecuados que puedan recibir la
asistencia médica y tratamiento médico
adecuado con lo cual desde amnistía
internacional seguimos exigiendo que se
lleva a cabo esa rehabilitación
inmediata porque ahora más que nunca es
fundamental y necesaria y al mismo
tiempo bueno pues exigiendo lo que que
la unión europea adopte unas políticas
migratorias que realmente faciliten las
vías
asegurarse que apuesten por una
responsabilidad compartida y por la
reubicación y el reasentamiento de las
personas que lo necesitan
y algunos países de europa ante los
reclamos por su inacción sobre la crisis
en lesbos anunciaron que acogerían a 400
menores que emigraron solos sin embargo
la cifra total de refugiados es de casi
13.000 le preguntamos a veronica barroso
de la universidad internacional si
soluciones de este tipo son suficientes
para dicha crisis donde además se suma
que los nacionales ya no quieren saber
más de los refugiados pues es una
solución más es decir no puede ser la
única solución sí que es cierto que
amnistía ha puesto el foco en los
menores por la vulnerabilidad especial
en la que estos niños y niñas se
encuentran desde ya hace mucho tiempo
porque bueno como saben están totalmente
atrapados en las islas pero
evidentemente la reunión lópez encauzar
medidas complementarias a esta es decir
tiene que adoptar las políticas
migratorias que eviten este tipo de
confinamiento y de estancamiento en las
islas griegas entonces bueno pues se
pide en eso que que realmente se adopten
políticas que se basen en una
responsabilidad compartida mente
los estados miembros y que además sean
políticas que faciliten esas vías
legales y seguras donde se puedan tener
en cuenta
el arraigo que puedan tener estas
personas que tienen ya familiares muchos
de ellos en algunos estados miembros de
la unión europea y que además faciliten
bueno pues unas unas medidas que en el
fondo lo que sea
tiendan a garantizar los derechos de
todas estas personas en lugar de
privarles y de restringir los derechos
que es lo que ahora mismo está
sucediendo porque no pueden salir de las
islas sin la autorización de las
autoridades griegas
desde hace años la unión europea no ha
logrado acordar una política de asilo
comunitario que reemplace soluciones de
emergencia como las tomadas en los
últimos días en moria la comisión
europea presentará una propuesta para un
pacto de migración y asilo antes de que
finalice septiembre que debería tener en
cuenta el bloque para responder
acertadamente a la crisis de refugiados
esto nos dijo se pactó la inmigración y
asilo se debe basar fundamentalmente lo
que he dicho anteriormente es decir en
una responsabilidad compartida de todos
los estados miembros y en políticas que
eviten la criminalización de las
personas migrantes y refugiadas que
están llevando nuestras fronteras a
europa y por tanto que faciliten esas
vías legales y seguras para evitar que
estas personas tengan que finalmente
llegar a nuestro territorio arriesgando
su vida es fundamental que se eviten
políticas migratorias y medidas como las
que están adoptando en los últimos años
y en concreto en los últimos meses donde
ha habido países como griega grecia
perdón que ha adoptado el medidas
amparadas con la unión europea que
suspendía el derecho
asilo en grecia esto no puede volver a
suceder es decir tienen que ser
políticas que refuercen y que garanticen
los derechos de las personas que están
llegando a nuestras fronteras
especialmente de los solicitantes de
protección internacional y en medio de
la emergencia en lesbos el éxodo hacia
la isla continua en los últimos días más
botes llegan a las costas griegas con
migrantes que buscan una vida lejos de
los conflictos y la guerra en sus países
hasta que inmigrantes de france24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
siga conectado con más información en
france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]